hey guys ryan right here I'm gonna be
checking whoa Alyssa I'm filming I'm
going to be checking out the second
trailer for the gunman this is a Sean
Penn javier bardem film it looked ok the
first time i saw it i pod me of our damn
looks like he's doing a good job but the
second trailer here is a little bit more
intense so let's see why it's rated R
for strong violence language and only
some sexuality what a disappointment
what you want please what are you doing
over there you order this native trigger
gentleman ahead feel
it's the things
we thought we were helping
you never happened that's the way you
want to play with me the company's their
house ever ever one of those days when
everybody wants to carry me for
something we have a surprise for you
it's a remarkable woman
it's of Jeff someone shoved it up
the gunman in theaters March twentieth
okay okay that does look like taken in a
lot of ways his wife is taken and now he
wants to tear down whatever company he
works for used to work for the storyline
looks pretty cliche guys like I felt bad
bet all my crimes from the past and then
now he's suffering for his sins and by
someone good in his life being taken the
action is not promoted that they're
showing a lot of like explosions and
gunfire one thing that made taken work
was like there was some pretty cool
action even though was a cheesy [ __ ]
film there was some pretty cool action
I'm hoping this film provides at least
some cool action Sean Penn looks
incredibly committed to this role you
don't really get that with action films
but he looks like he's going all out
with his Sean Penn intensity but there's
a whole caste assemble here that makes
me go this film must be good in some
fashion I mean I saw Adris Elba and
there he's great for these kinds of
crime thrillers Ray Winstone perfect for
these kinds of films too and of course
how can you forget about Javier Bardem
the first trailer that they showed I
thought Javier Bardem looks awesome in
this he's great at playing bad guys I'm
sure he's gonna do a great job in this
one as well like what looks better to me
about this it was like I don't know if
the parents to take him it's only
because it's the same director but would
take in what elevated it was Liam Neeson
still had a very committed performance
made it the film that much more
entertaining instead of just having Sean
Penn be the only committed performance
that got a bunch of actors in this film
that are known Sean Penn Ray Winstone
Idris Elba Javier Bardem you get all
them in this ensemble action piece
you're almost guaranteed to at least
have strong performances in this movie
even if the film plays out a little
typical plays out a little cliche as
long as the acting is solid and as long
as the action is solid you're in for a
good film but there's only some
sexuality that's a letdown and it's
rated R so if there's strong violence
and I'm sure I'll be more entertaining
what am I worries is that they'll take
this film so serious I feel like if they
had a look
bit of a humor about it it might be more
entertaining cuz like taking you know
like they took it really serious but
it's like because they took it serious
it ended up like a cheesy fun time this
one looks like it might be put together
a lot better and the faculty going all
out with making it rated R so the
violence is not I would love to see a
red band trailer for this actually to
see what kind of action they're
providing and see what kind of violence
and the level of gratuity that they have
going on I don't know if fortuity is a
rightward gruesomeness this fortuity
when you like give to charity I'm not
good at vocabulary anyway guys thanks
for telling me that trailer was out if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects where we
keep it our double e real Adam Gonzalez
what's up men and women rejects my name
is Adam and your bids play a huge role
in my life really excellent vids reviews
and reactions I would really appreciate
if you gave me a shout out make it out
to Bubba diesel 24 my gamertag may peace
be with you all and take care Bubba
diesel 24 ultimate gamer he's really
good at all the games he plays minecraft
pokemon blue edition um street fighter
two turbo on the Super NES he's really
up to date with all his games whoa you
look like an intimidating badass you got
one of those piercings right here ouch
they're probably into some kinky [ __ ]
you sexy [ __ ] yeah does that
help when you're doing like clitoris
looking does that like touch the [ __ ]
Bubba you nasty son of a [ __ ]